you
with me on the panel two CEOs of
wonderful entrepreneurial companies that
all let introduce themselves but they've
got great stories to tell and I think
also a lot of information to share about
thinking about when Patrick capital make
sense when venture capital doesn't make
sense the process of evolving and
growing a business as well as the
process of raising money and and what
are some of the ways to make sure that
you t yourself up for success when
you're in that environment so let me
introduce Matthew Monahan who is the CEO
of inflection which is a leading people
search company that he can describe it
in a bit more detail and Terry Austin
who's the CEO of Guardian analytics
which is a anti-fraud solution for the
online banking industry I happen to be a
board member at both companies but they
were the best two companies that i could
find I'm thrilled to be involved with
them both and I think it also is helpful
that one is more in the consumer
internet space and one in the SAS
Enterprise focus space so Matthew do you
want to talk first just a little bit
about her a little bit about the company
and then about yourself so whoever was
got a little bit of context yeah so I
sold a business prior to this it was a
consumer-based ebooks business that was
only about five people when we sold it
and then moved into inflection this was
in 2006 and so I started it with my
brother he was at Harvard doing this
from his dorm room and essentially the
thesis is that a lot of the public
record system is moving online right now
and there's a ton of data being
digitized and moving on to the internet
that hasn't been effectively organized
and so we saw an opportunity here to
build a platform to not only bring the
data in but then also package it for
consumers through a variety of channels
whether it's the search engines or the
social networks and so forth so today
we're up to about 100 employees we have
two main brands the first is called
archives com which is a family tree
family history website that allows you
to search your ancestors and the second
is called peoplesmart com which is a
search engine for people and the main
goal there is how do you solve people
search in a privacy friendly way and
then we have a bunch of other vertical
brands that we are adding data and
enrolling out including an identity
protection and employment screening we
raise money in 2010 middle of 2010 so it
took us about three and a half years
before we decided to raise our series a
deal and so up into that point we
bootstrap the company it's been
profitable since we started which is
something that we're very focused on and
very proud of and and it's a phenomenal
team of a bunch of great people and
we're just over here on University
Avenue great great background there's a
there's a whole bunch there that I think
is interesting in our great lessons in
that process about starting a business
evolving a business coming up with the
strategic framework for what's really a
good business and a defensible business
that that we can get into overtime as
well so Terry do you want to do the same
things you're a little bit about the
company in about yourself so people have
some broad context sure absolutely i'm
terry awesome CEO of guardian analytics
I've been CEO for two years the company
has been around for about five and a
half almost six years so I joined later
I joined after the company had done
their a round kind of a seed followed by
an a round though we've labeled it
differently i'll just use that and the
company had a product they had a version
one product and they had about six or
seven customers using the product so
there were certain proof points that had
been established and i've been there for
about two years and did a couple of
transitions of the company we're now on
version four of the product so we've
introduced some some pretty significant
revs and the most recent one was to move
to a SAS architecture to deliver this
product and a much more scalable and
fast-growing manner so the essential
solution is fraud prevention and online
banking as Greg mentioned we solve a
really mad
civ and growing and vexing issue
internet banking has been around for a
long time it's evolved quite a bit
there's new generation of internet
banking that's upon us with mobile
banking with all sorts of different
payment mechanisms being integrated into
the online banking system and one of the
things that doesn't get talked about
much is that fraud has grown and almost
outpaced the innovation online banking
itself and the protections that have
been in place to date have not really
been effective to stop online fraud it
keeps getting bigger more money gets
stolen the criminals are more emboldened
than ever and there's very little
repercussion for a criminal that gets
caught there 10 they tend to be overseas
there's not much jurisdiction that can
affect them they just move on to the
next victim and the traditional
techniques of either trying to protect
your computer or your mobile device with
antivirus protection or an email malware
protection have failed it's just it's a
it's a finger in the dike against a
tsunami that's that's hitting them with
malware propagation and authentication
techniques that are really an attempt to
put a really strong lock on the door any
of the most sophisticated multi-factor
authentication techniques have also
failed because they make the assumption
that once somebody successfully logs in
and passes whatever test you give them
then you can trust them and the fact is
that all of the malware that's loaded on
all these machines and mobile devices is
designed to defeat authentication and
once it's defeated and the criminals in
they can do all sorts of things to steal
money and extract value out of the
financial system so we take a radically
different approach to the problem we
assume that the endpoints compromised
them in authentication is defeated and
we use all of the digital information
that a user creates when they interact
with the online banking system to create
a very specific individualized
behavioral profile of that user and from
that we can we can actually very
precisely and very accurately detect
when somebody's logging in who's not a
legitimate user and we were now deployed
about 45 banks
and credit unions throughout the country
using the system we're targeting that
sort of long tail of the banking
industry there's about 17,000 financial
institutions that are our target market
in the US and that's that's the kind of
essential solution so so what I'd love
to do is to is to frame a little bit how
I think about entrepreneurial companies
and what I look for and what's
interesting to me but I don't actually
want the whole discussion to be about
about fundraising and about venture
capital because a big part of that story
is really about identifying good
businesses and good people and so you
know to me the the kernels in there that
are interesting is focusing on partly
how I'm evaluating you know what are
great people in you know great CEOs and
entrepreneurs so that you can chart your
course in an appropriate way and partly
what are what are really good businesses
and I think in both cases there are some
interesting anecdotes about
transitioning the business to be a
better business and and and that's what
that's what I'm most interested in but
there is a little bit of a framework
over that and we'll sort of bounce back
and forth with I think a couple of these
vectors the so I'm at sutter hill
ventures we've been in the venture
capital business in Silicon Valley for
48 years you know by virtue of doing
that I think we are not and don't try to
specifically be sector specialists in
the sense that i'm a SAS guy or I'm a
consumer internet guy or the like I
think of my mandate is basically
anything that touches software and comes
from software and the like you know you
have to evolve with the times and and
ultimately do that by figuring out one
how to be a business with great people
and to how to get into really
businesses and the way that I like to
say that some of my partners will say so
we're micro economic meaning you know
not the mattock right you think about
you know there are firms that are SAS
only firms without our consumer and it
only firms just like you look at the
marketing and mutual funds and some will
say hey well we're the Science and
Technology phone well we want to be is
the really good business with really
great leaders fun and you do that by
looking for my perspective the company's
unit of analysis not the sector right so
I don't come in and say and I really got
to be in the people search business I'm
going to go interview six companies in
the people search business I'm going to
figure out which of those is the best
because I've already determined that
it's a sector that I that I want to that
I want to be in there are people who do
it it's not what I do you try to
initiate that conversation in my
partnership you get thrown out of the
room and so you know people would say
find me a company you know let's talk
about a company right I mean you can go
meet with six companies talk about one
that you think is a good example it's a
little bit like thinking of it as the
case study method of you know of
studying here at the at the GSB and that
but that those basically do come down to
you know fundamental the economics of
the business do you daddy are you in a
growing sector is there an incumbent
leader that you're displacing our air
you evangelize in a new market do you
have unique and proprietary technology
are their business advantages that you
can build over time and you know that
either have or are pretty clear that you
can build over time and and then you
know the fundamental framework for
evaluating that is you know is it is
risk and reward and so you know you look
at you know lots of people come and say
hey well I'm building this marketplace
and you know once I have the buyers and
sellers I'll have this great defensible
advantage but of course barriers to
entry before you have them our barrier
sentry for you to write so you know one
of my partners always says well that you
know that's great that's a that's a ham
and eggs business model if I had ham and
if I had eggs that have ham and egg
but you start out with neither and it
really doesn't do a whole lot of good
the you know the people side of it is
you know it's really very you know it's
very nuanced right we're all just making
our own judgment Center and our own
assessments for you know some things
that are general and some things that
are specific to the opportunity and I
think the right place to start when I
think about it is is that in my
partnership the single greatest
compliment that you can give someone is
that they're intellectually honest you
know and and and both of these guys met
that test the question is are you
evaluating data and are you living by
the data and are you learning every day
and if something if you have a strategy
and it isn't working are you unafraid to
call it and a change and if you know
somebody can do that that stuff that's
the fundamental process and the another
way of saying it is that start starting
a company is a great truth-telling
device right the market doesn't lie and
if it doesn't like what you're doing you
got to do something different and and
there are you know there are plenty of
people out there who either only want to
hear good news who only want to raise
the next round so that they can keep
running the company and and so I think
that's just the you know the the you
know the basic piece it's also the case
that leadership matters right you know
you see it in in all kinds of
circumstances but but ultimately
entrepreneurial companies should not
succeed and the only way that they
succeed is by small bands of great
people taken on giants and accomplishing
things that shouldn't be able to be done
and in order to do that you have to
galvanize resources that you don't
deserve better quality people then you
know ought to be drawn in to these small
companies more capital and resources
than
and you know what a traditional
financial investor would be willing to
to provide partners and distribution
channels where people are taking big
bets on you that that they shouldn't and
in some logical construct and so I think
that notion that says intellectual
honesty leadership to galvanize and draw
those kind of resources enough self
confidence and humility to be willing to
consistently hire people who who are
better than you are in a specific domain
and and and then there are some really
complicated pieces about how do you hire
someone in a domain that you don't know
that well and the easy way to say that I
think is for a lot of people coming out
of business school tired of frankly i'm
going to hiring a CEO hiring up vp of
marketing hiring a product manager is a
relatively straightforward thing to do
hiring a VP of engineering when you're
not an engineer that's hard right hiring
a VP of Sales actually when you don't
have sales experience yourself really
hard because sales people know how to
sell and you know it's really hard and
to me those are the two biggest
challenges and most people if they're
going to become CEOs at some point have
to go from being really knowledgeable in
a function to being a general manager
managing functions where they don't know
as much as the people that they're
hiring and are working for it and that
and so that judgment that says boy is
this someone who can figure that out who
knows what they know knows what they
don't know is learning quickly enough
the stuff that they don't know and you
know that to me is is the is sort of the
central framework so you know I think
with that I'd actually like to turn to
to Matthew and I'll I'll give a little
bit about about what I saw in the
business when I saw them and then but
then asked him to tell this to
of the beginning and the evolution of
that business so first I'll say I was
totally impressed with Matthew the
minute I met him and you know as you can
see these two guys are different ages
they've got different backgrounds it's
you got a full head of hair you know
you'll be grateful for that the and and
so it's not that that you know what I
actually try and look through someone's
age or exact experience or the like and
I'm trying to infer qualities and
capabilities and I think that the the
some of the things that I referenced are
just you know crystal clear in Matthew
Wright dedication to the company into
the task commitment to be in fact driven
running more experiments and learning
fast or including failing faster than
anybody else had already demonstrated it
you know in spite of being a relatively
young CEO that he'd been able to hire
people more experienced in certain
disciplines and and be able to attract
talent I think that's always one of the
challenges for a relatively relatively
young CEO and an incredible sense of
self knowledge and humility and
willingness to learn from all places
right not not that I or the other
investors are you know our pontificating
from on high were 11 input among many
and he's out talking to business
partners and talking to other CEOs and
just learning and and and picking it up
so if there ever a time where you said
this is a guy who is great and getting
better every day you know this this is
the guy the other thing that I think is
interesting and that points out just a
little bit about the the venture process
is that there were a couple of things
that gave me a little bit of insight
into the business right so one of which
is I just done
big genealogy project and so I had some
personal knowledge of the space the
second is that I'd done a bunch of work
in monetization and lead generation and
ad targeting and while they're using it
that technology stack for a very
different purpose it was a technology
stack that I was relatively familiar
with so I think for anybody that you're
trying to pitch the business to they're
having one or two of those access points
that tape things that might feel a
little mysterious and make them really
easily understandable as a is a big
difference so that that was my
orientation coming into the business now
Matthew can tell you how the business
started and you don't actually you know
grew to that point some of the decisions
they made along the way cool thank you
for the kind words so when we started
the business we had about 75 to 100
grand and seed capital from the proceeds
of the lost business so that's some of
the context on self funding it but we
were able to do that and self fund that
business from there over the few years
one of the key things that I went into
Silicon Valley I moved out here in early
two thousand seven I had a very strong
skepticism of VCS and I actually would
encourage you all to have a strong
skepticism of bbc's except for Greg no
but but in all seriousness I think that
you know you hear a lot of horror
stories you hear a lot of stories of
entrepreneurs saying hey you know don't
raise money if you don't have to or I
got booted from my company or something
like that and so I came in with my
guards off I was very fearful of even
going down that path over that process
and and we had a business model where if
you could figure out how to make a
dollar 10 for every dollar that you
invested in promoting the products that
you can scale it relatively well and I
also have the distinct advantage that I
had a co-founder who between us we knew
how to kind of build the sites but the
e-commerce engine together and do the
marketing without needing too much other
talent although you know engineering
talent was the first the first folks to
hire so I would echo from an
entrepreneurial perspective what Greg
saying about the people mattering the
most I think it's mattered the most to
us in terms of the team that we brought
on board and then it's been a huge
factor in consideration in terms of how
we
selected the VCS Greg and then also josh
from matrix partners and and so my
personal philosophy is just kind of copy
what other people have figured out so on
the hiring front we do smart and gets
things done those are kind of the two
criteria in terms of how we think about
position part of getting things done
means that they fit in culturally and so
you know no no rule we want to
make sure that people are you know going
to fit into the company and do well but
that formula Google's repeated it
there's been a lot of engineering blogs
that have talked about that smart and
get things done and then on the partner
side which we would consider our
investors to be partners it's Warren
Buffett's model which is people that you
know people that you like and people
that you trust and I just think that
that's the best wisdom I've been able to
find on how to select partners is you
got to get to know them you got to like
him and Greg's a very likable guy and
and you have to trust him and I think
integrity was it was always really
critical to us in terms of selecting an
investment partner partly because we
were a little bit skeptic of bringing on
money skeptical bringing on money as
entrepreneurs so how we went down the
process was we basically friended a
venture capitalist back up back up about
two years because i think you mean part
of the interesting thing that i want
these guys to hear is how did you go for
three years without raising any money
because i think that's a that's actually
a big part of it too so in 2007 the
gentleman that had purchased our prior
business he was in North Carolina he
made an introduction to his roommate
back from Harvard Business School and
one of the recurring themes i didn't go
to business school actually dropped out
of undergrad but one of the things that
has happened since I've been kind of
trying to scale the organization
everything else is those of you who are
in business school the connections that
you guys are getting cannot be
underestimated do not underestimate them
hugely important in so many ways can't
can't reinforce that enough play nice
everybody and part of what part of what
on that front just slide tangent here
but when if you're not an engineer and
you need to hire an engineer or if
you're not a sales person you need to
hire a VP of Sales I think part of the
way to solve that is through weak ties
and there's been a lot of studies that
you know the more weak ties that you
have the more more successful you will
become and I think having a lot of weak
ties of people in diverse interest
groups which is a great you know
business school is a great breeding
ground for that in many ways in terms of
the university environment you could
build a lot of those weak ties and you
never know when those phone calls are
then those contacts are going to be
useful but but that aside the first
thing I did when we started the business
was I had a mentor that had kind of
introduced me to email marketing or to
internet marketing long ago and then the
gentleman who had bought our prior
business we brought them in as advisors
and they had some stock in a company but
they didn't have any board seats we
didn't have a board there was none of
that but they kind of serviced us as
kind of a functional board if you will
because we didn't have a formal kind of
people who were giving us feedback and
supervising us as the entrepreneurs and
as the co-founders and that worked
extremely well I think that you know
getting advisors people you trust
whether it's a professor whether it's a
friend whoever but getting people that
you respect and feel are knowledgeable
in certain areas to advise you on the
business is really important and they
introduced us to a gentleman by the name
of Jason green who is a venture
capitalist over at emergence capital and
Jason and Rick one of our advisors had
been roommates Jason we purely met from
a hey this is an entrepreneur hey this
is a guy trust you guys should get to
know each other because you're new to
the bay area and what Jason did was he
invited me to one of the VC events that
emergence capital puts on where you know
you have this big atrium and all these
people you know cocktails and food and
so forth and it was there that we met
our first executive and so this was the
path that we took but basically it was
there that I met a gentleman by the name
of John spottiswoode who would run match
com from 97 to 2000 he had a very
illustrious career in an Internet
helped a few companies go public and we
basically maintained very low salaries
for the first I think nine months we
didn't even really make anything and
then after that it was like thirty
thousand dollars a year we were putting
all the money into executive hiring and
John was one of the first executives
that we brought on board it also brought
another executive who is named donald
land worth and those guys made a
humongous impact on our business because
what they did is they took a lot of the
business development they took a lot of
the operations completely out of our
mind share our being Brian and I out of
our mind sure that we should focus on
the products in the marketing so for us
getting the products in the marketing
nailed really is all that mattered and I
think one of the most important lessons
that I've learned in terms of that
experiences anything you can do to
reduce your plate and and continue to
focus on the few things that you really
have to get done for everything else to
develop take advantage of those
opportunities and and don't
underestimate them try not to do
everything as an entrepreneur you want
to do everything try not to do
everything try to make sure that you're
nailing the really important stuff you
know and if I draw that theme from a
couple of other examples that I've seen
and the thing that I think Matthew and
Brian did so well is think of themselves
out of the gate as founder and VP of X
right so so there isn't you know the way
that entrepreneurial companies succeed
and especially our are really don't
require a ton of capital is is one as
much probably more focused on getting
stuff done then on being smart and even
when there's a team of founders
everybody there is no room for overhead
right so the the you know picking out
those two most important things and say
they're too important for to be done by
anybody but the founder so I can think
of another example merced systems where
I'm involved in basically says one of
them I said I got product the others
that I got sales and he turned out he'd
never really sold anything before but he
but he was really really good at it and
for the for the first two years they
just did it right he did the first 10
sales by himself and I think that notion
so you
you want to be focused enough so that
you develop the functional expertise you
hire around it but you got you to you
you just gotta get in and do it and get
it you know and get stuff done and these
guys have done an exceptional job I
think of doing that yep so how we got to
the capital part and to close the loop
and say a few nice things about VCS
because i started with negative side
what we did is we actually found that
hey this introduction from jason
resulted in executive higher we need
more help hiring we need more help
understanding the business and so we
started developing relationships with a
lot of different venture capitalists in
Silicon Valley I would say that Fisher
capitalists are kind of like the nodes
of activity that are happening in a lot
of the different industries and
companies they have amazing visibility
into what are the decisions getting made
at the leadership level what are the
board meetings looking like and so forth
and so as an entrepreneur you can
consume a lot of information that's
really valuable all entirely for free
over lunches coffees drinks whatever
with a wide variety of folks and most
venture capitalists when approached will
definitely sit down and meet with you
and so the key thing on developing
relationships on that front that I
learned was make sure that you are
receptive to advise and you're going
with kind of not a full cup you're
making sure that the cups a little bit
half half full or three-quarters full so
that they can give you some some
framework some tips and so forth and
then don't come back to them until
you've implemented to some degree what
they told you to implement I think it's
very easy to say oh yeah that's a great
idea but you know it's not what we're
doing or something like that and it's
disrespectful to then ask for help again
and ask for help again if you're not
actually implementing and so what I try
to do is just kind of keep track of what
people are bison is to do and if they
you know if it makes sense for us to try
and so forth we'll do it and hey here's
what we did and it's a formula that
worked really well for us so after a
while I had gotten to understand more of
the VC process still you know 100 hour
weeks into the business and just putting
the sweat equity in bootstrapping it and
then we decided that we needed for the
business reason to be better capital
and a lot of what drove that decision
was our ambition we were seeing success
in the marketplace but we had multiple
verticals and therefore we had multiple
competitors and we didn't want to have
to small the balance sheet to go after
and so we decided to go through a formal
process of picking seven or eight VCS
that we enjoyed meeting that we knew and
that we had some degree of an early
relationship with and we went through
the process I don't know if you want me
to go through the nuances of that but
what ultimately resulted was choosing
among a few term sheets Greg and Josh to
be our partners and to raise that
capital and by that time there was a
long relationship and they met all the
tests have know like and trust they
understood our business and we were able
to do a deal that we felt was win-win on
both sides I mean the thing that I think
is symmetrical in that is that
longitudinal data really helps about
people right so they've gotten to know
us over a period of time I think you
know you'd actually known the matrix
guys for longer right but but that does
really help and so in the same way I
think just developing those
relationships will give you confidence
that you're working with high quality
people but it will also give other
people confidence as they say oh well we
talked about this last time you told me
you were going to suit the way I think
about is you told me you were going to
do X you know you came back did you do X
or do you have a good reason why you
decided X wasn't the thing to do why was
right the the one nuance I'll put on
Matthews point is I mean I just always
want entrepreneurs and CEOs to make the
decision this is not the case
necessarily with all board members are
all venture firms but I'm perfectly
happy to be an idea machine but the last
thing I want you to do is to go
implement everything that I say because
that's a recipe for disaster right I
mean ultimately the guy working 100-hour
weeks knows more about the business than
anybody else in the world right and has
gotta take all that day to be the place
where to get synthesized and things are
prioritized and makes the call about
what to do and what not to do and I'd
much rather have that conversation about
what are the three things you're going
to do what are the ten things you're not
going to do and they can change from
time to time because I assume that
you're
they're learning and getting smarter
every day in the things that we really
enjoyed about Greg and Josh and I
continue to have a philosophy around is
that venture capitalists who have been
in your shoes are better than venture
capitalists who have it and so people
who have been in operating roles at
companies or have started companies they
just they understand and speak a
language that's easier for an
entrepreneur to get really insightful
advice about the operations of the
business on and and that's been that's
been extremely helpful and the other the
other piece that's been extremely
helpful for having these guys on is
continuing to get introductions to
people to scale the team so as you think
about the value-added venture
capitalists it's expensive money in a
traditional sense you want to mainly do
it when it's the right time for the
business but they will introduce you to
a lot of people or have those
connections available if you want to
take advantage of those introductions in
our case we did and that's been a huge
source of referrals in terms of people
join in our company right i mean my
philosophy is that basically there are
four rules of venture capital once
you're an existing investor the first is
physician do no harm right if you do you
know don't try to run the company don't
meddle where you don't have information
make sure that the CEO is running the
company the ultimate responsibility of
the board is hiring fire and CEOs uh and
then there are three places where I
think you can be generally useful one of
which is a strict strategic guidance and
pattern matching I mean I'm you know I'm
sitting on 10 boards you know I probably
sat on another 10 or 12 over the history
of time you just see a lot it is a job
where you're a bit you know a mile wide
and an inch deep you know if you're
really good you're two inches deep
brother than one but but I think that
does allow you some pattern matching and
the second is your you know you're a
business development arm of the company
and the third is your recruiting arm of
the company and those are the three
places where you can really help so the
four rules are don't hurt and help in
those three places and and you're doing
your job so wanna flip over to Terry for
a second because i think the you know
this is a bit of a you know of a
different story right on some level you
say well Terry is a you know
professional CEO
Oh had been a CEO before had been a COO
before that you know in in very
successful company and and so but I
think also came in and told a story that
just because a presentation is just
telling a story right you're telling it
in 20 PowerPoint slides but you're just
telling a story and and just you know so
this happened for me probably i don't
know 8 15 16 18 months ago and it just
like it just all clicked you know so you
know 45 minutes of presentation and all
those pieces work now we just went ter
just got successfully raised a follow-on
round of venture capital with a friend
and regular co-investor of mine and
another good guy who you know again
people matter right Mike ho Investor's
they matter a lot right and so but I
think it'd be interesting for Terry to
talk a bit about how we frame that we
actually loaded up his his presentation
on the on the on the computer here not
for him to flip through the whole thing
but I think there are some key slides
that are you know potentially good
examples to say you know your company is
different but you have to have one that
looks like this that solves this this
problem so I don't know if you want to
talk a little bit more about fundraising
the process first let me give you a
little context on the company what
stages have went through when Greg
invested I'd probably add a fifth to
your list of things to help with and
that is fundraising in the next round
targeting focusing finding the right fit
because there are a lot of VCS out there
and being able to you know I'm not an
expert in who the VCS are and what they
focus on but Greg is and was able to
really get us very focused in this in
this round we've raised 27 million
dollars today we just raised 11 of it we
announced it this week we raised it a
couple couple weeks ago that's
essentially our series see Greg invested
in our in our series the essentially
series b which is a hard round to invest
in
because you have to have you kind of
have to have a shared vision with the
investor about where the markets going
there's not enough the way I'd
characterize it is in some ways A's a
little easier because it's all promise
if you believe the idea is big and the
markets big and the people are smart
it's all promise you don't have any
reality to bet on yet so you're betting
on the dream be you have some reality
and it's not all good you know the
company had a product that work could
solve the problem we had six or seven
customers but hadn't added customers
very quickly we didn't have a lot of
repeatability you know so Greg had to
believe in enough of the vision of what
we could do with the proof points that
we had and had to believe in the team
and you know that we'd be able to
execute on the fundamental things that
we needed change to make the business
really really turn and sort of have the
patience to see that through with you so
you know we found that in Greg and
sutter hill and it's been actually can I
can make a couple of additional
observations right because it's this is
again sort of my framework as an
outsider coming into the business and
what made that work because there's one
other thing about the company right
which is it went through its you know
series a but but over two and a half or
three years I mean all with foundation
capital who's a you know good firm as
that as the investor right but kind of
two and a half or three years and you
know eight or nine or ten million
dollars like it it spent some time
looking for its for its future trying to
get product market fit and the I
actually you know me I'm always trying
to say when you walk in the door do you
have product market fit is is the
fundamental question and not has it been
a completely linear path there are a lot
of people who wouldn't want to look at
something that's been around for three
years and it's just getting there that
doesn't bother me at all right and but
then to this same point you say well how
do you what are the access points that
made it easy to make a couple of those
bets so you know the first is Terry
right so the fact that
story was so clear and crisp and well
articulated and that when you
periodically drill down into something
he had good thoughtful answers even if I
didn't agree with him necessarily they
were thoughtful and well thought out and
there was a rationale behind him and the
and you know that really matters the
place where it's hardest to do that
honestly is is in the financial model
because it's all assumptions in who the
hell knows right but even the notion
that says hey look you've been clear
about who your customer segment is which
features they need how your pricing
what's path to market and that it's all
lined up and strategically consistent
right basic stuff but a lot of times it
doesn't show up but the the you know the
other thing about Terry is we have a
very close mutual friend right a good
personal friend of mine who had worked
closely with Terry in the last company
and I'm telling you it's an example of
the you know of the weak ties just makes
a difference because I can call up one
guy and say just tell me the truth right
and and and so that makes a big
difference the second is that this whole
predictive analytics technology stack
which nobody else is using an online
banking fraud prevention but lots of
people are using in mont you know
internet monetization and ad targeting
and the like so i was very familiar with
the technology stack even though it had
been was being applied in a totally
different place and i had experts that i
could bring in to say you know can you
help me come kick the tires and if it's
a completely different technology stack
where I don't know the experts it's just
that much hard to get my arms are on and
the third is the target customer
segments my sister runs one of these
banks right and so I mean I've I grew up
knowing you know for most people you say
oh well I'm selling the community banks
and they're like well I don't you know I
do business with Wells Fargo or be if
hey I don't know any of that was right
you know not used to sell until and
venture-backed companies aren't usually
selling to them and and I you know so
again I come back to that notion of
these little access points demystify so
when you're looking for you know an
investor it sometimes is worthwhile from
uh the entrepreneurs side going through
that we talked to a few firms to raise
series b and series b was hard to raise
because we had been around for a few
years and you know we had some reality
but not a ton of proof on where we're
trying to take the company and you know
that there were some VCS who went
through really deep diligence with us
painful excruciating diligence and you
know if you had I didn't necessarily
feel like I had a lot of choices at the
time but if I did feel like I had a lot
of choices the fact that they were
taking me through such excruciating
detail diligence would have been a sign
that we're probably not aligned greg did
diligence it wasn't painful he asked for
information but he had a lot of touch
points already and he had a lot of
confidence in the technology stack in
the market and the viability of it and
he wanted to vet the things that he
should vet but it wasn't so you didn't
feel like you were reading the rationale
behind the business every time you
interacted with them which was in some
cases you know that's a sign if you keep
explaining the same thing to your
potential investor and they keep asking
the same questions over and over that's
not alignment you know that's not good
alignment it they may think it's a great
idea and want to invest and want to
believe but it's you really need I think
everybody said it but cultural fit
chemistry and alignment are probably the
most important thing in getting this to
work is going to work together through
thick and thin and your business plan is
not going to be what happens your
business plan is a spreadsheet and a set
of projections based on your best
information right now and things are
going to change and you have to know why
you have to be thoughtful about why you
have to be thoughtful about what to do
next when things do change and you know
you can come in under your plan you come
in over your plan but I guarantee you
you're not going to come in exactly at
the plan you put down when you go talk
to an investor about funding the
business and we've we've done both we've
done both together and the reaction and
the reason that you know when you know
you have alignment is when you know the
the quarterly results didn't come out
the way you expect it and you're low
and the reaction is well let's
understand the fundamentals what's going
on what's your assessment of why and are
the basic premises about how we're
building the business that the customers
are still buying it that the market is
still receptive that your product plan
is still tracking are those all still in
place ok let's go forward and in fact
you know what I can remember one
quarterly meeting after Greg it invested
where the management team was so sort of
distressed at not having made their
numbers that Greg and the other
investors were actually being the
cheerleaders in the board meeting
explaining to our management team why
hey everything you're doing is pushing
the rock up the hill and things are
going to get better because you're
executing on all the fundamentals that
we all believe in so it wasn't about
this kind of maniacal focus on why did
you miss this number why didn't you get
this deal closed it was on the
fundamentals and the metrics of the
business and that that's real alignment
that's real sort of alignment on why
you're doing it and I you know I think
it's been a great great partnership from
that standpoint I'm serious see
essentially which is what we just raised
is a different round a lot you know we
were able to with our series be money
execute a lot of things that we wanted
to execute we were able to transition
the business to a SAS model able to
restructure our pricing and our
go-to-market approach we were able to
develop some channel partnerships that
are starting to pay off and we were able
to get a level of repeatability into the
sales model that you know it's still not
going to be perfect and it's not going
to trend exactly how we think we were
able to competently say look we've got a
couple of quarters under our belt where
we said we're going to sign as many
customers we did we're deploying quickly
we've transitioned to the SAS model it's
working so we've got a lot of vectors
that are working still a lot of
uncertainties but it's more you know I
think of series see as you've hit a pace
where you're repeatable and somewhat
predictable and you want to for some
fuel on the fire and grow on that
predict ability of repeatability so the
actually one of the things that I that I
want to do in two different ways with
these two different companies is
actually pull on this thread of what
I'll call you know transitioning the
business
and you know when you decide to do it
and how you do it and what are the risks
in doing it and I think in the
inflection case it's launching new
product categories right and so I think
the the one of the guys who I have a
tremendous respect for is ben horowitz
whose mark n driessen's partner at
Andreessen Horowitz Ben and I were
product managers together at Netscape
and I and earlier in my career and he
was one of those guys that I look at and
I say oh he's doing the same job i am
but he's just much better at it and and
I think as but you know to me
interestingly i would say that is that
you know that's how you learn right i
mean babies learn because they mimic the
adults and the older kids in their
environment and i think you know the the
life lesson is you surround yourself
with great people and you learn what
they're doing and mimic it and I have
this theory coming out of business
school that I just learned by running my
own experiments and learning faster it
turns out that that's a much lower way
to learn and it's a lot easier just go
to great companies with great people and
learn from what they do you'll make
plenty of your own mistakes along the
way but you know one of the things been
said when he was running ops where is
basically launching a new product
version 1 point 0 of a product is the
single hardest thing we do you know I
have many product managers or
engineering leads who can do version 2
and 3 and 4 when there's a bunch of data
and their customers to talk to version 1
point 0 is brutal and there are only
four or five people in the company that
I trust to do that who got enough
intuition about product market fit and
if I don't have one of those people
available I won't let a project start
I'll either not do it or I'll buy it and
so I think you know if you maybe want to
talk about launching you know big new
products because I think that is part of
what opened up the business opened up
the available market for the company and
put it on a bigger stage yeah how many
people here are interested in launching
a consumer-facing type of product just
so I can get a sense of it's a consumer
Internet this is the most so
b2b know okay so for us I mean vulajin
products really tough the the number one
lesson set of lessons I got was by doing
it to feed myself when I was in college
I had no money I was working six bucks
an hour at some work study program was
going to school and I was trying to
figure out how to sell ebooks to high
school students on how to get into
college and so I was writing sales
letters and creating marketing material
and then try to convince people to do it
and doing it over the phone and that
actually was the best single learning
experience because when you're when
you're at that stage you you quickly get
the lessons it's much better than than
reading it out of some book but you know
taking it up a level I think that you
want to be data-driven you want to be
quantitative Greg talked about that it's
one of our core values at our company
we're constantly looking for folks who
are analytical and who are thinking what
we call it not intellectual honesty we
call it thinking clearly at inflection
where they a clear thinker is one of our
benchmark kind of questions on
interviews and so you want to be
listening to the data because we all
have ideas ideas are a dime a dozen and
we all can have intuition about what's
going to work but at the end of the day
users will surprise you no matter what
and so I think listening to that data
and what we've created is it's still you
know continuing to morph and form an
inflection but we've created essentially
a loop where you have kind of a product
manager someone who's the quarterback of
the product that you're going to launch
or the feature it could be either and
then you have engineering who's going to
build it you have design who's going to
design it and preferably do wireframes
mock-ups everything else and then you
have an analyst who's going to continue
to research the data understand what
it's saying in report back and that
feedback loop with some QA involved and
a few other functions is is really kind
of the magic formula for us we've
launched a ton of websites and features
and products at inflection and what
we've tried to do is along the way look
at the patterns for
us of what are emerging and then put
those into the platform so that we can
continue to be faster at launching
things I will say that the most
successful launches we've done have
always been you know the three weeks
before that no one slept hardly at all
everyone was up all hours of the night
there are always millions of more
details to make these things work than
you ever expect going in there is no
replacement for just hard work rolling
up your sleeves and getting it done and
I think that you need to be working with
people that you know you can go to war
with in that regard I remember you know
myself and one engineer being at the
office in all hours of the night one
time when we were launching a website
and just looking over and thinking like
if I just didn't inherently trust this
person if I wasn't if we weren't both
totally on the same page this would have
never worked we could have never gotten
this this far and companies are so
bureaucratic once they start growing
just by nature of adding a lot of people
to the company that I definitely would
never underestimate the value of you
know whoever you're working on with that
initial product launch you just got to
make sure you guys are on the same page
and the same wavelength so so
archives.com I mean you know basically
has has become you know half the
business or something right and you know
it was a you know it's a two-year-old
product right so it was launched two
years into the history was it one you
know one more website among among many
that you've launched when you guys
decided to do it or was it a did you
know it was a big deal and you know
therefore was launched with more for
thought yeah me it's a combination of
all things but you know just the
metaphors we use you know throw the
spaghetti against the wall see if it
sticks we use an agile development cycle
and so oftentimes we're throwing things
against the wall and if they start
gaining traction we add more resources
to it if they if they really look
exciting or promising then we really dig
in we may throw away everything that
we've already done to date because we
think it's such an opportunity that we
need to build it you know in a more
substantial way but one of the things
that an entrepreneur friend of mine told
me that that's really stuck with me is
don't wait opportunity
equally you'll see so many opportunities
in your business for improvement it's
easy to lose sight of the fact that some
opportunities are you know 50 times more
important than others you know hiring a
really phenomenal VP of engineering
versus you know fixing the code on that
on that one site or optimizing the
checkout process I'm like that they just
can't be weighted equally they can't
make it to your to do list equally they
can't consume your mind share equally so
for us we saw that hey there's this baby
boomer demographic shift this half of
the United States we're acquiring all
this historical data that it doesn't
look like a lot of people are actually
acquiring when organizing and everything
from census records to newspapers to
obituaries to death records
internationally and we see that people
online are very interested in genealogy
meanwhile the leading company in the
space ancestry.com has a product that's
over two hundred dollars a year which
doesn't really appeal to a beginning
person who's interested in their family
history There s one provided a wealth of
data including the fact that fifteen
percent of folks in the United States
express an interest in family history
that's kind of interesting and we
started putting all these pieces
together and said you know what this
makes sense so the first site we
launched was called genealogy archives
com and it was doing amazingly well
right from the get-go and it had a lot
of headroom and so we went out found the
person that owned archives com they
weren't using it we made a big bet
because we didn't have VC money and that
was an expensive acquisition but we'd
made a big bet from retained earnings
put the put the bed on the table and
we're now the number two family history
website our products 40 bucks year for
unlimited access we're growing very
rapidly in that category and it's got a
lot of headroom ahead so I think that's
kind of the story of how we did it you
know I think from there I would just
love to maybe ask you know QA when we
get to a of what other nuances that can
go into yeah I mean the thing that I
think is interesting about consumer
internet products is there's so much
feedback and there's so much data and so
you know product management the product
market fit piece is always some part
analytical and
some part some part creative and the
creative part is what do you put out
there to test right so unique if you
don't have some bit of that creative
instinct or judgment about what people
might want then you can put a bunch of
things out and they'll all fail it
didn't get the right kind of people to
make those judgments you hopefully often
the founder right one of the founders
then you can start analyzing data and
figure that out you know I think the
other half of the of the transformation
piece and this is one of the bets I was
willing to make a tag guardian that I
think except maybe some other people
weren't and that has gone exceptionally
well but it's really really hard is in
service of trying to create a better
business is the this transformation to
SAS so from excuse me enterprise
software that a customer deploys in
their own environment on their own
hardware to to a SAS based solution and
I wonder if you can talk a little bit
about both what that was like to
actually do but then also how
transformed that it's been to the
business model yeah it's been huge and
you know in it and it wasn't a
technology decision it was the strategy
decision and it was a market decision to
begin with I'll give you a little of
that context we start the company
started out like most security companies
in the financial services space saying
we've got to get bank of america and
Citibank and Wells Fargo and you know
that's going to validate the product and
put us on the map and they tried that we
tried it for a couple years before I got
there but we tried it for a couple years
I think the biggest banks we succeeded
getting were like Zions pretty
good-sized bang first republic silicon
valley bank you know some decent-size
banks but not the really big guys and
then we were starting to have some
success with smaller banks regional
community banks but we were this on-prem
model and we and you know you had to
deploy it they had to buy a server they
had to start an IT project we had to go
on-site we had to stand up the system we
had to integrate to all the different
possible databases and opera
rating systems that big IT shops have we
inevitably with bigger banks ran into
the well let's just tweak this customize
that fit it into our environment in this
way so every job was kind of this big
massive effort to get it working and we
looked at the market and said well look
there's 17 thousand or so banks in the
u.s. 30 of them are really big and
looked like Bank of America and Wells
Fargo and the other 16 thousand nine
hundred and seventy don't and most of
those guys actually buy their online
banking system from one of about ten
providers there's into it there's Fiserv
there's fidelity there's Jack Henry and
a handful of others so the markets
actually consolidated around these
internet banking platforms and these
banks by outsourced services because
they buy their internet banking platform
from a centrally SAS provider I don't
think they called its ass when they
first introduced those things but and
they buy solutions they don't want to
buy something and rip it apart and
reconfigure it to fit into their custom
environment and they make decisions and
oh by the way they're also completely
under protected from fraud and the
fraudsters have figured it out and have
started attacking them so the problems
really migrated from the big banks down
to these small guys so we said that's
the market we should go after that's
really who's going to buy our product
but to do it we have to have a SAS
solution for all the kind of cost and
complexity issues but also that's the
thing that this markets going to buy so
we decided to make that transition it
was not an easy decision to make we put
a lot of thought into it and we had to
raise money in the midst of that and say
well we've decided this for these
reasons and we know we can execute and
make this transition to SAS and that's
kind of a scary prospect because
companies try to make the transition
from on-prem to SAS and it's not not
always easy we were lucky in a couple
ways one we didn't have to change our
business model we charged a subscription
for our software from the beginning so
even though it was deployed on Prem we
didn't have to change the way people
paid for it and two we knew that this
was going to be hard so we
hated it we hired a really extraordinary
netops person who I'd happen to know
through previous companies he worked
with me at good technology and his boss
worked with me at good technology and at
a market live so I knew him he had a
pedigree and I knew he could set it up
and he could do it and he was willing to
really put the effort in to do it from
scratch and we knew we're dealing with
personally identifiable information
about account holders and thanks in our
hosting center and we're a venture back
startup so we knew security might come
up in the conversation so you know we
anticipated that from the get-go and we
went and talked to these banking
platform providers and to our existing
customers and said give us your security
audits if we came to you with a hosted
solution what's the security audit you
would put us through and we got a half a
dozen of these security audits and we
also got an outside a consulting firm
that does security audits for a living
for banks and we designed our SAS
solution based on those security audits
so we're SAS 70 level to comply on all
those things but we also have a dozen
security audit checklist from real banks
in our file drawer that we checked off
as we were designing and building the
SAS solution so when we migrated and
we've gone out and we started selling
and they said well how do you pass the
security audit and they pull out there
as we've got that's part of the Venn
diagram we've already solved for all
those things and we haven't had a single
issue we haven't not gotten a deal a
single deal because of security concerns
which is one of the things that kept me
up at night for nine months while we've
made the transition to SAS so it was it
was very successful and by the time we
actually turn the switch on the on the
SAS solution was just this last this
past August I think we had 17 customers
on Prem and all but three have said
definitively they're going to migrate to
the SAS solution so that's pretty good
and we've added 25 or so new customers
to the SAS
solution so talk about things like you
know deployment time frame time frames
to value you know sales cycles and the
light because I think this is part of
the benefit of the SAS business model
and it just has been proven out in space
well its massive deployments for our
on-prem customers took four to five
months the actual work was less but the
elapsed time to get them to set up the
IT environment secure the servers get
everything set up they had to launch an
IT project and then we had to do a bunch
of on-premise stuff it took four or five
months we're doing deployment on
platforms that we know in two or three
days now literally four months two days
the 17 customers we had we're all on a
different version of the code on Prem we
all of our SAS customers aren't exactly
the same code base and we do a weekly
release we do a weekly bug fix and
feature update release every week every
Thursday there's a release meeting we
push a new stack of code out every
Friday every customers on the same code
base and in fraud prevention that's a
big deal because the criminals are
changing all the time and we have a
customer right now that we're trying to
save who's still on Prem who's on like 4
revs back because they haven't gone
through the hassle of updating and they
said you know you're not stopping all
the fraud we're like well for dot to
does that exact rod case we stopped last
week at another bank on 42 but you're on
30 we can't protect you with today's
fraud with yesterday's code stacks so
having the SAS solution has been kind of
revolutionary and then just the you know
there's there's an upfront fixed cost
but every incremental customer that we
add to the SAS solution the marginal
cost or that customer is very very small
so we can grow to a couple hundred
customers without really adding any
significant fixed cost to the business
and it becomes a very very capital
efficient model so thanks for your time
and attention and
you know we'll hang around to get more
questions after the pent